that person i'm absolutely more than
that i mean the skill set that i have is
[ __ ] wild compared to the average
person so
that's why i said i fully know my value
and i can't but you didn't you didn't
you did acknowledge that you were
aggressive though yes absolutely because
i know that like listen i was raised by
my father and he does have a little bit
more of an aggressive personality i was
not raised by my mother and even so my
mother is not like a super soft super
maternal kind of person um
but i like the fact that i have this
personality because i know how to stand
my ground when necessary does it serve
you well it does absolutely because
people who truly care about me and
understand me know that i'm just
standing up for myself and i know how to
speak
and articulate myself properly
people on the other hand get quickly
intimidated by that
because they don't have the same ability
to speak for themselves the way that i
do you know i would say i don't think
it's intimidation
i would say it is acknowledgment of the
fact that
they're not willing to engage with
aggressive behavior
and so a lot of the time so that is
intimidation no no no it's not it's
actually something why is this actually
why yeah it's actually always
a decision so it's like if somebody
keeps bringing aggressive behavior to to
me
as a man i would say
i have to make a decision as to whether
or not i am going to deal with that and
i'll be like you know what nine times
out of ten yep especially if it comes to
a woman i ain't willing to deal with it
but here's the thing
is on your side you might see that as me
being intimidated by you i'm just saying
listen i hear you're aggressive and i
can see you're aggressive but you know
what yeah go give that to you and there
isn't there is nothing i ain't got time
for there is a nation prophet that says
a man will rather be in the wilderness
than come home to a nagging wife
nagging and nagging
he would rather live on the roof
nagging and aggression are not the same
thing
i okay but that's not the case for me
i'm just going to how can i interpret it
okay you guys don't understand that
we're talking about things that i'm
passionate about so of course i'm going
to be a little bit more aggressive and a
little bit more passionate in the way
that i carry myself in this conversation
however
when it comes to normal conversation i'm
chill like genuinely
just be chilling i'm usually very calm
and i'm usually just very like i'm
excitable laughing so you could so you
could change your tone depending on the
subject yes exactly i don't think you're
a bad person i just think yeah you do
have an aggressive tone see the thing is
growing up i heard consistently that i
was intimidating usually from girls it
was you were intimidating because you
were pretty and you know yourself and
from guys it was i can't handle that and
unfortunately that's not my problem
i hate to say it but like if you can't
handle it that's fine
that that just means that you're not
meant to be around me
i can't handle aggressive women
because women are not supposed to be
aggressive and to be handled
if that makes sense like i don't think
we're supposed to be handled or
tolerated or anything like that right so
i would i so if you're an aggressive
woman i would literally in my own head
say okay cool she needs to go and be
with a man that's gonna be uh okay with
that i'm not okay with that because
you know the i guess the bottom line for
men generally
is that aggressive women
come with a lot of problems do you know
what i'm saying i'm i'm not trying to
like
i'm not trying to like sorry i'm i'm
waiting for the still resigning in this
comment i'm just saying that
if you're aggressive and you but you say
if you're looking for a man or a partner
men generally do not want aggressive
women
they just don't you know that's
a very interesting statement because i
have dated quite a bit of men
in my life but you haven't stayed with
them
you haven't stayed with them i haven't
because
probably you've probably like
not not manipulated so probably meant
that you
have been um
the man in the relationship no because i
have been authentically myself from
beginning to end in each release
i don't like that when people say i have
to be authentically myself if i said i
have to be authentically myself i'll
sleep with any attractive girl i see
that happen
what connection does that make because
i'm a little confused authentically
himself
yeah but i'm just saying that we have a
base nature but the whole point of it
you have stuff but my base nature is not
just sleeping with a bunch of people
that i find attractive though that's
your base nature so you're speaking for
yourself there's always a toxic shadow
side to each human being we are we all
have a dark side right that's what i'm
saying i never said that i was only good
i said i was authentically myself but i
think his question is like what is
authentically yourself you know what i'm
saying like so he's saying like
when you say that change the way that i
act in order to attract apartment uh and
a partner
just to end up changing up later on
yeah yeah
so i would say like
you know half the time that these
relationships didn't work it's either
that i wasn't emotionally mature enough
or i left for college or i have other
like i'm very i'm a very individualistic
kind of person and especially within the
last few years like you know i graduated
from my bachelor's program i graduated
from my high school program like i was
involved in so many different jobs and
activities and social justice work
that sometimes relationships didn't
really fit in with my agenda
and i would just be like hey like you
know i realized that this is not my
priority right now i realize i have to
focus on myself i feel like i'm still
too young to get into a relationship or
like i'm too young to get a little too
involved in this relationship
maybe it could work later on but right
now it can't yeah right and plus you
have to bear in mind that things your
mentality probably will change in the
next couple of years or so so that's the
other thing that's why i kept making it
clear that in the relationships that i
got cheated on i was very young like
now like it's a whole i have a whole
different perspective on how
relationships should work and
generally a mature you know vision of it
however a lot of people our age are not
built for relationships i hate to say it
and
well i think social media has kind of
ruined it because it makes us think we
have options options options
in the candy store
yeah
right when we have and the thing is like
the dating app market is so powerful
among us
and like you know how many matches do
you guys think you have on a dating app
i okay i can tell you this i don't know
this is terrible you were on tinder
though
uh
i thought that was like two years ago
because it's lockdown
did you match him on tinder i can't
remember if it was tinder or hinge i
have i have been on like this yeah
last year
even in the beginning of this year but i
just don't use them anymore because i
just if i'm honest i think i think
they're [ __ ]
i've never been on one well i was just
thinking like you have so many options
yeah the point is like when you open a
dating app like all of us would probably
have like 100 like when i was about like
this is like terrible like genuinely
terrible but when i was about like 18 or
19
i had bought tinder gold just to see
like how many likes i have what is that
tinder gold is a subscription basically
like it's like a premium version of
tinder so you can see all the people
that liked you instead of it just being
blurred out like because there's an
option where it says like 99 plus likes
but they have you like pay for it so
that you could see who liked you
oh
yeah and then there's other options
where like even if you don't match the
person in the app you can message them
right so you can still message them even
if you're not connected at all you know
they they don't want to match with you
hon like don't don't message me exactly
i had that happen to me several times
when i still had instagram like they
they saw my instagram in my bio and
they'd still go out of their way to
message me even though we didn't match
but when i did buy tinder gold i had
about 8 500 likes
like that's nuts that's a lot of people
for me to sort through like and i think
out of the 8500 i only matched about 800
of those people like i sat down and i
was like [ __ ] it like i went through all
of them yeah i did it with my friends
and we were like you know what let's see
what's going on here and
it was probably the nuttiest thing i had
ever experienced with a dating app and i
will never do that again to be honest
because what the hell
but it's like
to think that i have that many options
right i think that there's that many
people that want to take the time i'm
not going through 800 people
you've never been on a dating app on
instagram really
never why
because i don't need it okay fair enough
i'm a [ __ ] god
i think it's better personally to meet
people in person
and you have the whole person because
then you've got an
energy and if you meet a person in
person it's it's usually i say this it's
usually in a place that you both want to
be like a music event
yeah you already know you've got a
common interest on
social media and on the internet anyone
can be anyone no that's also because i
was in a 10-year relationship yeah yeah
no i had no i prefer meeting people in
real life to be honest because on i've
never actually like
dated someone off of uh like a dating
app so clearly they don't work that well
one of my most successful relationships
was actually off bumble oh really yeah
like what's bamboo
another dating app
so the difference with bumble and tinder
is that
women have to message first and your
match will last 24 hours so you have to
hate bundles
no that's a no for me but i mean i think
i like that because it changes the
algorithm i like hinge i can i can put
on more filters
you know you know exactly what filter
you meet
that's the whole problem especially with
instagram because everyone is so
accessible like i'm saying it goes back
to the kitten in a candy store it's like
a bigger mix yeah you know it's bad for
you but you're going to try it and then
you're like oh i should have just stayed
with my original candy oh i should have
moved in
for three months kirsty you know
it's the only choice i had i think what
makes it harder is that our parents
obviously like at least for our
generation our parents didn't grow up on
social media you know so they can't tell
us how to navigate it and how to
properly carry ourselves on it because
they barely understand it themselves i
can't wait till the next 50 years when
we have the we see the fruits of all
these social media and they when the
social media generation
moms
have
the only fans so many she said that this
generation is going to be the generation
of grandmas that have got bbls and
facetimes oh my god
bbos and facebook but actually i
actually think though that's my
in the next couple of years there may be
a backlash where but we go back to the
old traditional model because they say
this i think i think what's happening
though i think there will be like uh a
push to go back to more traditional
i think once like a certain amount of
gener like i feel like that actually
started happening already because like
remember when kylie jenner started
removing her lip fillers yeah well like
yeah people immediately were like oh my
gosh she did she did get back with her
baby daddy
you know men
men are more
men's role has been more traditional
kind of more consistently and the
women's role has been more
i don't know in this generation has been
a little bit less traditional yeah
because we have to compete though
compete with who you're competing with
other women in order to get a partner
but there's also a lack i think of
masculine men and a lot of men that are
addicted to porn or corn yeah yeah and
because
so i think like the problem is like on
both ends like i do think there's a lack
of wives but i i think there's a lack of
husbands too i agree with you because
there's a lot of guys that are just like
all they want to do is play video games
and like but you know what guys dude
guys are generally like an adaptor die
type individual so it's like
for me uh sorry let me speak for myself
so if i i was in like a ten-year
relationship right
and
when you get back out into the market
you're like okay what's going on out
here do you know what i mean what's it
like and then on the streets yeah i'm
back in the streets
and it's like you're newly
you kind of realize that
things have changed
and you're you are going to have to
adapt to the market you can't bring your
old ways that you were like do you know
i mean so
i think men have a easier time adapting
to the market yeah whereas women
will hark on whoever they've created in
their head about themselves
and they will stick to that this is what
it is
[Music]
that's what i'm saying no i just like i
think women settle a little bit more
no no actually you know what i think
it's kind of people what's your standard
i changed my mind on that because i know
that a lot of men end up in unhappy
marriages because they end up with the
woman that they know is going to stick
by their side rather than the woman that
they want the whole time here's what i
think i feel like i've seen a lot of
them because we're practical yeah our
practical we're thinking long term but
then if you're not truly
caring for that person it's like why
would you put yourself duty we're going
back to duty and he's thinking
you know what but why are you treating
life like it's a duty it is that's what
makes it easier why do you think
societies were built do you think
societies were built off like like some
kind of whimsical memory were built
because people wanted to feel better
than other men knew they had a duty to
build the society that is why society
was real and protect you they knew this
meant men know this they know that you
know what i might not like it mm-hmm
right but it has to be done i don't i
don't think there's one i was yelling
everybody was barking at me but when
he's yelling nobody said a goddamn thing
because he's he's not because you kind
of when you do it it's like
like you're mad almost like i don't
think he's mad he's just what i'm saying
i'm not mad either oh okay i thought you
were earlier yeah yeah
i'm not saying you know i'll be honest
like i just always look like a dick i
think more though it's like
how do i put it i'm just saying men
understand duty yes i i don't think
that's because duty was put on you by
what
society but but yourself the patriots
but who creates society who creates
society the people everyone of course so
that's what i'm saying like it's you
can't you can't blame society if we make
up society it's also the people who have
control though like for example like the
christian church you know like they
controlled society for a long ass time
it's only within
with that but also one of the fruits of
christianity was that especially in
europe there were shell sacrifices
what is that i said what child
sacrifices
in europe were obviously going through
the
evangelizing the germans and the
and they had also rituals child
sacrifices they're putting them to that
stuff so
there's good and bad what happened to
them
i would agree that when you get into the
government and you get into power even
jesus said render to caesar what is
caesar to god what is god because you
can't legislate morality it doesn't work
hang on you can legislate morality but
when people try it doesn't work because
you're forcing it it doesn't because
there is a
morality is actually subjective it's not
objective right and that's why people
tend to think that morality is actually
objective it's not it depends on the
society in which you
you're raised in yeah yeah but i don't
know
there are basic rules that certain
things are wrong like incest rape murder
less universal incest is wrong yep you
think incest is wrong yeah and you're a
christian yeah
so how it was normalized
this is going off a little bit okay so
when
the flood happened to christianity yes
and there was noah yeah his three sons
yes
and their wives yes
eight people yep
eight people yep
yeah do you think there was no incest
that was insane but then again it became
i'll tell you
theologically speaking it was made
illegal when the law of moses came
he did not hang on
you said before that incest is wrong
yeah i just showed you according to your
own stuff no i'm giving you that incest
is okay i'm giving you a chronology the
bible [ __ ] up a lot of times yeah so
i'm just giving a
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't think there's a such thing as
settling i think everyone gets the best
that they can get
i
that's like me okay imagine imagine if i
so i went to um a school called elmhurst
college okay
and i i didn't apply to harvard but if i
did i probably would have been rejected
so so but i don't go to elmhurst and say
wow i settled
no i got into elmhurst
and i feel like in dating like you get
what you deserve and if the places that
are accepting you
aren't aren't good right you probably
don't deserve the good ones but i think
settling is more of a mindset like it's
just dealing with what you think you can
deal with at the time because you don't
think you deserve better
i i think that's a trap again i think
again i think you i will one i think you
attract what you are yeah so i think if
you keep dating people that are toxic
and crazy like there's something about
you that's toxic there's also an adverse
to that it also could be someone that is
like
they have a problem with wanting to fix
people constantly right
that is very common like there's always
like the narcissist versus like motherly
nurturing
i think that's a way that women
take
a lack of accountability
like genuinely because they they put all
the blame on the other person oh he was
the narcissist i'm just the fixer and
this is coming from someone i've been in
a toxic relationship and i was toxic at
times so you can't you it takes two to
tango
because like i just don't think you can
put that all on the other person yeah
but people tend to do that though yeah
because they like to seem like they were
right all the time like yeah nobody
wants to look like the villain yeah and
it's only when you fully understand
yourself and know that you're not
perfect that you're like [ __ ] it if i
was the villain in your story's need to
accept that and give grace to each other
that's for relationships to work yeah no
grace